في الاثناء كشفت القناه الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه ان رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو منع
رئيس المساد ورئيس الشباك من المشاركه في
اجتماع امني وصف بالحساس واوضحت ان
الاجتماع كان يفترض ان يضم بالاضافه الى
رئيس المساد ورئيس الشباك نتنياهو ووزير
الدفاع ورئيس الاركان وقال ديوان رئاسه
الحكومه ان نتنياهو لا يمنع رئيس المساد
من حضور الاجتماعات الامنيه موضحا انه
يحضرها وفق جدول ل الزمني المحدد كانت
القناه الاسرائيليه قد كشفت ان نتنياهو
منع وزير الدفاع خلال الاسبوع الاخير من
عقد اجتماع امني يتعلق بالاسرى
الاسرائيليين في غزه بحضور رئيس
المساد معنا من رام الله ابراهيم ربيعه
الاكاديمي والباحث في العلوم السياسيه
استاذ ابراهيم اذا صحت هذه التقارير التي
تبثها القناه الاسرائيليه ماذا يعني منع
رئيسي المساد والشباك من حضور اجتماعاتي
مفترض انهم اضلاع فاعله ومؤثره
فيها اولا ربما العوده قليلا الى الخلف
نتذكر التوتر بين وزير الجيش الاسرائيلي
ورئيس
الوزراء هنالك حاله من عدم الثقه بين
الطرفين وبالتالي ربما يكون المستهدف بهذا
هو وزير الجيش تحديدا لمنعه من الدخول
بالعديد من التفاصيل الامنيه خارج سياق ما
ما يسمح له بهذا اتجاه علينا ان ننتبه ان
نتنياهو يريد ان يذهب بالحرب بعيدا بناء
على تقديرات سياسيه اولا
بينما المؤسسه العسكريه والتي يمثلها جانت
بالاضافه ايضا الى الاطراف الاخرى في
كابينه الحرب لديها تقديرات عسكريه وامنيه
اكثر وبالتالي هذا التناقض يعكس نفسه في
ظل هذه الحاله هنالك حاله من التوتر في
الفضاء في الحقل السياسي الاسرائيلي اي
هنالك حاله من الحسابات السياسيه المتصله
باليوم التالي للحرب لا تتصل بالشان
الفلسطيني تتصل ب مستقبل كل لاعب من
اللاعبين السياسيين وبالتالي هذه الحسابات
دخلت مرحله دقيقه واعتقد ان
الصعود الملفت ل وزير ال او رئيس الاركان
السابق وعضو مجلس الحرب جانس هو يستهدف
نتنياهو بشكل اساسي وهو يقلق نتنياهو
ويشير الى ان جانس اصبح جاهزا اليوم
التالي ليكون كما يريد رئيس الوزراء
القادم وهو يقدم نفسه كما كان منذ البدايه
يقدم نفسه على انه ال السياسي الجمعي
السياسي الذي يمثل الحاله الوطنيه ولذلك
هو قبل بالدخول بهذه الحكومه وكان هذا
الدخول الى هذا المجلس مجلس الحرب كان
مشروطا ومتصلا بعدم العمل مع الصهيونيه
الدينيه وجاء تحت الضغوط الامريكيه ايضا
وبالتالي كل هذا المشهد المعقد يعكس اولا
هذه السلوكيات في العلاقه بين نتنياهو
ووزير جيش من جهه وما يحدث في كابنه الحرب
وما حدث بالامس من سحب مقترح نقاش اليوم
التالي للحرب ا يفترض في ان ان اسرائيل في
حاله حرب ويفترض كذلك ان تتوافر للحكومه
الاسرائيليه في هذه اللحظه تحديدا اكبر
قدر من التماسك والاتحاد الذي لا نراه في
الحقيقه من خلال هذه الانباء التي تاتينا
تباعا حتى من وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه متى يمكن القول ان هذه
الحكومه وصلت الى نقطه التحول او نقطه
الانهيار اولا حاله عدم الثقه بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه هي حاله سابقه للحرب كان
هنالك حاله استقطاب وهنالك حاله من
التوظيف المشخص او التوظيف السياسي
انتقائي للمنظومه القانونيه محاوله تكييف
النظام السياسي الاسرائيلي لصالح
الصهيونيه الدينيه واليمين وهذا ما اخرج
الشارع لاكثر من عام في اسرائيل وبالتالي
حاله الاستقطاب هذه جاءت وانعكست على
تقديرات الشارع الاسرائيلي تجاه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وتجاه رئيس الحكومه رئيس
الحكومه هو الوحيد الذي لم يعترف
بالمسؤوليه عنما حدث في السابع من اكتوبر
ولم ذهب باتجاه المكاشفه مع الشارع
وبالتالي راكم من حاله عدم الثقه في
علاقته مع الشارع واستمر بنزيف الدعم له
سواء من الشارع الاسرائيلي بشكل عام او
حتى من النخب السياسيه وبالتالي هذه نتيجه
ما يحدث اليوم نتيجه اعتقد ان ما ما يحدد
مستقبل هذه الحكومه ومن يحدد مستقبلها هو
ثنائي كابنه الحرب نتحدث عن جانس وايزن
جووت وتحدي حديدا جانس في حال قرر
الانسحاب من هذه الحكومه اعتقد ان الشارع
يكون مهيا
يضا يعني المرحله التاليه في علاقته مع
هذه الحكومه ربما ايضا يكون هنالك انسحاب
من قبل الصهيونيه الدينيه في حال استجاب
نتنياهو للضغوط الامريكيه وهذا غير مرجح
لان مصير نتنياهو ومستقبله السياسي اقرب
لحلفائه وشركاؤه في الصهيونيه الدينيه وفي
اليمين المتطرف بشكل عام وبالتالي هذا هذا
غير مرجح ولكن في حال حدث ذلك نحن نتحدث
عن نهايه نهايه هذه الحكومه بكل الاحوال
نتنياهو امام هامش مناوره يضيق شيئا فشيئا
بين خيارات مقيده بشكل كبير ويريد ويجب ان
يستجيب للضغوط الامريكيه التي ستتصاعد ب
بعد الاعياد بشكل مؤكد ايضا هو بحاجه
لاستجابه لكل ما يحدث ميدانيا هنالك
انسداد هنالك ضغوط متصله بالمباحثات وما
الى ذلك وبتالي هذا الهامش يضيق وامام
نتنياهو خيارات صعبه